merci Laurence Cohen de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes sénatrice communiste du
Val-de-Marne Vice-Présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales et vous
avez remis à votre rapport sur la
pénurie de médicaments on va longuement
parler mais d'abord on l'a vu dans
l'actualité Emmanuel Macron était à Pau
hier il a dit la première réponse c'est
l'ordre et le calme la Concorde et
ensuite c'est de travailler sur les
causes profondes vous partagez ces
propos écoutez moi je bien sûr je
condamne toutes les violences qu'elles
soient mais je pense que le Président de
la République et son gouvernement ne
prennent pas en compte la réalité de
terrain c'est-à-dire effectivement des
quartiers qui se sentent abandonnés de
la République et puis il faut revisiter
le maintien de l'ordre tel qu'il est il
est promu aujourd'hui et revoir la
police l'émission de la police nationale
il faut une police de proximité à
l'écoute et aujourd'hui les policiers
finalement sont utilisés pour un
maintien de l'ordre extrêmement musclé
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il y a des
souffrances parmi les policiers qui sont
extrêmement importantes parce que il y
en a un certain nombre qui ne partage
pas cette stratégie mais malheureusement
et bien le gouvernement remet sans arrêt
une couche avec plus de plus de
sanctions plus de répression mais c'est
là aussi remis plus de policiers sur le
terrain c'est l'objectif de la
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur que vous avez voté il y a
quelques mois ça suffit pas c'est pas
seulement mettre plus de policiers sur
le terrain c'est qu'est-ce qu'on leur
demande de faire or on a vu que les
policiers sont en fait utilisés pour
faire passer la politique de Macron qui
est particulièrement impopulaire je
pense aux répression au moment de toutes
les manifestations et je pense surtout
au fait que il y a des ordres qui sont
inadmissibles aujourd'hui nous
condamnons en tout cas nous au niveau de
ma famille politique les contrôleurs
faciès nous condamnons ce rapport à la
jeunesse qui est extrêmement mauvais et
si ça ça n'est pas
remis sur le tapis pour revisiter cette
cette politique et bien il n'y aura rien
de particulier et puisqu'on ne les élus
locaux et notamment les mers c'est des
moyens des moyens financiers pour
pouvoir effectivement développer des
services publics pour pour que la
République elle soit présente dans tous
les quartiers et qu'il n'y ait pas des
des endroits qui soient délaissés comme
c'est le cas actuellement est-ce que
pour vous les émeutes les violences de
ces derniers jours sont derrière nous
est-ce que vous redoutez une nouvelle
flambée la semaine prochaine le 14
juillet écoutez je ne peux pas prédire
ce qui va se passer moi je suis comme
tout le monde satisfaite que les les
tensions se soient apaisées mais je
pense que les gestes qui ont été faits
par le gouvernement c'est-à-dire de ne
pas accorder d'argent au niveau des
maires de ne pas les écouter de ne pas
écouter c'est la colère qui gronde dans
les quartiers etc comme ils n'ont pas
écouté la colère par rapport au
retraites ne présage pas des lendemains
apaisés Emmanuel Macron qui a aussi dit
hier d'évidence nous avons un problème
d'autorité dans la société qui commence
par la famille est-ce qu'il y a une
responsabilité des parents dont ce qui
se passe bien sûr qu'il y a eu des
responsabilité
des familles
c'est clair ça serait ridicule de la
sous-estimer mais est-ce que c'est ça le
fond du problème est-ce que c'est ce que
nous avons attendu nous avons entendu
des des jeunes qui disaient qu'ils
étaient abandonnés donc quels sont les
gestes que produit le gouvernement face
à cette colère moi je n'en ai vu aucun
si ce n'est de dire on va dire sur les
choses et beaucoup de répression enfin
on a entendu parler jusqu'à sanctionner
ces familles ce que propose notamment
les républicains c'est-à-dire de toucher
aux allocation familiales des parents
des métiers mais non c'est complètement
ben voilà aujourd'hui on constate et
malheureusement aussi au Sénat le
mercredi lors des questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement un ton extrêmement dur
il faut réprimer il faut sanctionner la
photo étrangers la faute au précaire etc
c'est une méconnaissance totale de la
réalité de terrain et ça n'est pas si
réponse là qui doivent être entendus
donc faut que que LR arrête de courir
après le RN et que le Président de la
République retrouve aussi raison et
donne des moyens pour qu'il y ait plus
de services publics voilà et quand il y
a des quand il y a évidemment des
violences qui sont commises par contre
qu'il y ait effectivement des sanctions
c'est évident mais des sanctions qui
soient des sanctions pénales vis-à-vis
des responsables on va parler de votre
apport dans quelques secondes mais un
mot sur un autre rapport qui a fait du
bruit et rincer le Sénat qui a donc mis
ses conclusions sur le fond Marianne
dérive d'un coup politique manque de
rigueur opacité désinvolture on conduit
au fiasco c'est ce qu'a dit
Jean-François ils sont est-ce que vous
demandez au gouvernement d'en tirer les
conséquences écoutez moi je trouve qu'au
niveau du Sénat il y a eu plusieurs
commissions d'enquête dont celle-ci que
c'est un travail sérieux et qu'il faut
prendre en compte les conclusions de de
mes collègues parce que elles sont
étayées et donc quand il y a un travail
parlementaire il faut que le
gouvernement puisse suivre je dirais pas
toutes les recommandations mais la
majorité n'a plus sa place au
gouvernement ça sitôt c'est au président
de la République dans les idées on va
parler de votre rapport rapport sur la
pénurie de médicaments que vous avez
également remis hier Mathias 13 nous
rejoint il va nous en dévoiler les
principaux points
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Oriane
la commission d'enquête sur la pénurie
de médicaments donc rendu son rapport
hier et il est alarmant plus de 5 mois
la Commission d'enquête dans la
rapporteur est ici présente sur ce
plateau à pied auditionner plusieurs
composantes de ce qui fait aujourd'hui
la galaxie du médicament les médecins
l'industrie pharmaceutique les
associations de consommateurs le
gouvernement mais aussi d'anciens
ministres de la Santé pour tenter de
mettre en lumière les dysfonctionnements
qui ont mené à la situation de pénurie
que connaît la France pour certains pour
certains principes actifs alors l'un des
premiers éléments du rapport c'est que
cette situation elle est grave Oriane
37% des Français ont été en 2023
confronté à une situation de rupture
d'un médicament au moins deuxièmement
c'est que cette situation est bien elle
est multifactorielle déclin de la
production française une concentration
d'échelle de production notamment à
l'étranger rendant vulnérable
l'approvisionnement et enfin une
stratégie commerciale des industriels
vers les médicaments innovants et
onéreux au détriment des médicaments
anciens
peu cher mais pour autant essentiel et
l'un des points soulevés par ce rapport
Matias et qu'il y a peu de contrôle et
de contraintes envers les industriels
les plans de gestion des pénuries
document stratégiques de gestion de
crise que doivent obligatoirement
fournir les industriels ne date que de
2010 et en réalité la qualité des rendus
est très inégale mais comme l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament n'a
que peu de moyens pour traiter ces
données il n'y a peu ou pas de politique
de répression et c'est un problème comme
l'explique la présidente de la
commission d'enquête Sonia de la
pauvreté car l'État lui soutient bien
les filières qui dit accompagnement
positif notamment au travers du crédit
d'impôt recherche je suis dire et que la
chaîne de valeur elle ne peut pas
exonérer de la question des industriels
de la production parce que voilà on a
besoin de gens qui fabriquent tout ça ça
dit aussi derrière contrôle ça veut dire
aussi sanction et donc cette partie là
de la politique publique elle peut pas
être moins traitée moi prise en compte
dans la prise en charge globale que que
le reste
du coup qu'elle recommandation fait le
rapport alors il y a une liste de 36
recommandations réparties en deux
catégories tout d'abord celles qui
permettent de lutter en urgence contre
les pénuries pour juguler le problème
contrôler par exemple davantage la
crédibilité des anticipations des
industriels systématiser le
déclenchement d'alerte des médecins
lorsqu'un médicament manque ou encore
évaluer l'opportunité de constituer des
réserves stratégiques ensuite selon vos
recommandations il faut s'attaquer aux
causes structurelles des tensions vous
proposez ainsi de faciliter les hausses
de prix des médicaments essentiels si
les industriels s'engagent à sécuriser
l'approvision l'approvisionnement
renforcer les moyens de contrôle de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et enfin établir une
stratégie claire de relocalisation en
France et en Europe avec différents
leviers de pression madame Cohen est-ce
que c'est un rapport de force qu'il faut
installer avec la puissante industrie
pharmaceutique sur ces questions de
santé publique en tout cas il faut que
il y ait à nouveau au niveau niveau des
puissances publiques une reprise en main
on a vu et on constate et vous l'avez
très bien exposé comme la présidente que
je veux saluer vous avez exposé il y a
une faillite en fait du système c'est
une remise en cause du de la politique
du médicament donc il y a à prendre à en
tirer tous les enseignements d'autant
que la pandémie a exacerbé les tensions
les ruptures mais on voit bien que ça
n'est pas c'est vraiment systémique et
que on ne va pas elles ne sont pas
derrière nous les les
pénuries donc quelle mesure il faut
prendre il y a un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises comme vous
l'avez souligné depuis 2010 seulement
mais on voit bien qu'elles sont
insuffisantes l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament fait un travail
énorme nous les avons auditionné à deux
reprises mais finalement ils sont quand
même très absorbés justement sur la
gestion des des pénuries et il faut leur
donner des moyens pour effectivement
effectuer des contrôles bien plus bien
plus nombreux bien plus réguliers et
puis en tirer les conséquences c'est à
dire quand une entreprise est
contrevenante elle doit effectivement
avoir des sanctions et des sanctions
financières notamment qui sont
dissuasives pour c'est pas parce que
dans votre rapport vous le dites vous
dites il y a il existe ce pouvoir de
sanction mais il est pas appliqué
pourquoi bah il est pas appliqué je vous
dis pas Parlement que de moyens de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament qui fait quand même des
contrôles qui sont pas suffisamment
réguliers et puis il faut des exigences
beaucoup plus précises par exemple quand
on demande des plans de gestion de
pénurie les fameux PGP et bien nous nous
avons eu l'occasion d'en éplucher
beaucoup et vraiment la qualité de ces
de ces plans est extrêmement variable
c'est-à-dire que ça n'est pas renseigné
il faut que les entreprises qui
produisent donc des médicaments est-ce
que le médicament est une marchandise
nous nous répondrons non le médicament
est un bien commun univers à partir de
là il faut qu'il soit il soit protégé
qu'il soit sorti de la loi du marché
alors que des entreprises
privées comment dirais-je fabrique des
médicaments d'accord mais qu'il y ait
une reprise en main au niveau de la
puissance publique et donc on vous savez
que moi je porte le pôle public du
médicament avec mon groupe le groupe
communiste
citoyen et écologistes mais en fait il
faut nous avons réussi à faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un consensus au niveau de
nos recommandations et une de nos
recommandations extrêmement importantes
justement c'est qu'il y ait cette
possibilité de production publique au
travers notamment de la GEP c'est à dire
de de cette de cette agence qui se
trouve au coeur de l'APHP et qui peut
donc qui pouvait il y a quelques années
fabriquer un certain nombre de
médicaments mais là encore il faut lui
donner plus de moyens et il faut par
rapport à la liste des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeurs en
sortir une cinquantaine à peu près pour
que il puisse y avoir cette production
également publique avec sous-traitance
etc etc donc ça c'est important et puis
il faut qu'il y ait un pilote dans
l'avion on a constaté qu'il y a une
multiplicité d'agence qu'elles font
toutes effectivement elles assurent leur
mission sauf qu'on a l'impression qu'il
n'y a pas au bout du bout la décision et
la décision elle doit être politique
c'est pour ça que nous proposons un
secrétariat général sur ces questions là
alors justement dans ce sens vous avez
demandé un rendez-vous au ministre de la
Santé François Braun et Roland Lescure
ministre de l'Industrie c'est pour aller
vers cette organisme que que vous portez
bien écoutez on les a auditionnés tous
les deux donc déjà en amont parce qu'on
a fait un travail assez
extraordinaire en ce sens où on a fait
54 auditions 119 personnalités qui ont
été qui ont été auditionnés donc
maintenant on veut leur rendre compte du
de notre rapport et effectivement comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de démissionner dans
le cadre de la Commission faire social
le ministre de la Santé je lui ai
demandé de nous recevoir pour qu'on
puisse lui donner nos conclusions il y a
un certain nombre de conclusions que
vous avez vous avez rappelé mais il y a
celles que je donne aussi puis attention
à la petite musique sur la hausse des
prix on a on a on a attiré l'attention
en fait sur la
le besoin de revisiter la clause de
sauvegarde parce que à l'origine elle
était faite sans que les les médicaments
les plus anciens soient impactés
aujourd'hui ils sont impactés donc il
faut remettre les choses à plat la
situation a évolué et on a dit il peut y
avoir en fait une révision des prix
extrêmement bas de certains médicaments
matures mais à condition qu'il y ait des
engagements stricts de la part des
entreprises c'est à dire s'engager à ce
que la France soit approvisionnée
s'engager dans le long terme et puis il
faut aussi quand il y ait donc de
l'argent public Sonia de la pauvre la
pauvreté la souligner quand il y a de
l'argent public qui est insufflé ce qui
est le cas au niveau du domaine du
médicament mais il faut qu'il y ait des
contreparties aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de conditions c'est-à-dire que écouter
le Crédit Impôt Recherche quand même
c'est 710 millions pour l'industrie de
la pharmacie on leur demande rien mais
vous vous effectivement vous mettez des
conditions à la hausse du prix du
médicament mais est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
dire aux Français qu'il va falloir payer
les médicaments plus chers si on veut
assurer la souveraineté en matière de
médicaments de l'Allemagne a augmenté le
prix de ses médicaments est-ce que la
France va devoir le faire aussi écoutez
moi je crois que c'est un faux problème
ça et d'abord c'est très facile de dire
voilà il y a une cause nous on a
démontré dans notre rapport que c'était
multifactoriel donc déjà il faut avoir
ça en tête et puis on a vu que dans
d'autres pays notamment en Suisse ou il
y a eu en Suisse en Allemagne comme vous
l'avez dit où il y a eu une hausse des
prix et bien ça n'a pas ça n'a pas
modifier les choses il y a toujours la
pénurie des médicaments donc il y a un
espèce de chantage et le CEPS
c'est-à-dire cet organisme qui s'occupe
de négocier les prix avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique et pris en étau donc il
faut arrêter ça il y a l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui effectivement joue
fait un espèce de chantage et vous voyez
des prix peut-être de médicaments
anciens qui sont indispensables qui sont
bas mais vous voyez des prix de
médicaments dit innovants qui s'envole
avec des traitements qui coûtent des
fois 1,9 à 2 millions d'euros ce qui est
absolument scandaleux parce que en
attendant les industries bénéficient de
fonds publics et les médicaments sont
remboursés par la Sécurité Sociale donc
vous voyez un peu ce sont les
contribuables qui payent vous l'avez dit
on parle quand même docteur économique
très puissant est-ce que la réponse elle
doit pas être européenne finalement si
on veut qu'il y ait des réels
conséquences derrière
nous avons émis comme comme
recommandation il y en a 36 il y a
effectivement des recommandations qui
incombent à la France j'en ai donné un
certain nombre un certain nombre
d'exemples parce que il ne faut pas
attendre l'Europe il faut que la France
agisse tout de suite et elle peut le
faire si elle veut le faire donc s'il y
en a la conviction et la volonté
politique et juste un mot là-dessus
parce qu'Emmanuel Macron en juin 2020 il
a annoncé un plan de reconquête en étant
en pleine crise covid est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez l'impression
que les choses ont avancé sur ce sujet
alors Emmanuel Macron fait toujours des
des déclarations tonitruantes et
toujours très percutantes il a même dit
que le médicament était un bien commun
ce que je partage que j'ai dit au début
de mon propos mais après comment se
traduit au niveau des actes par exemple
on parle de relocalisation des
entreprises c'est une très bonne chose
c'est ce qu'il faut faire mais on il
faut aussi raison garder c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas relocaliser toutes les
entreprises en France c'est pour ça
qu'il faut une coordination au niveau de
l'Europe et dans ton gratte un peu au
niveau du nombre de de projets qui sont
réellement relocalisés sur les sur les
produits stratégiques les médicaments
stratégiques il y en a que 5 un dernier
mot puisque vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure que la crise n'est pas derrière
nous ça veut dire qu'il y a un risque
cet hiver de revivre les pénuries qu'on
a connu l'hiver dernier bien sûr bien
sûr si on ne change rien nos systèmes ce
système a montré ses failles et donc
s'il n'y a pas de décision nouvelle qui
sont prises alors il y a eu la
publication de plus de 400 médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeur mais
dans un grand désordre là aussi parce
qu'il faut que le gouvernement fasse
attention à sa communication elle est
elle est très compliquée elle est très
floue pour être sympathique donc les les
patientes et les patients sont
complètement affolés parce que ça un
coup ça va bien un coup ça va pas bien
sur la liste des médicaments on a vu que
la Haute Autorité de Santé n'avait pas
été associée il y a pas eu d'études
particulières sur les conflits
éventuellement d'intérêt va voyez on a
quand même l'impression que c'est de la
materie et nous on a dit avec la
présidente Sonia a provoqué c'était un
peu en clin d'oeil qu'on avait eu
l'impression pendant toute notre notre
commission d'enquête qui a duré 5 mois
que le gouvernement courait un peu après
ce que disait et faisait cette
commission d'enquête alors il ferait
mieux de travailler en coopération avec
nous merci Mathias à tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure on va parler d'une autre
commission d'enquête une autre salle du
fond Marianne
dans le club on va continuer évidemment
avec vous Laurence coin on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions on va
Clermont-Ferrand on retrouve Julien
Bonnefoy Julien merci d'être avec nous
journaliste et chargés des opérations
spéciales du groupe Centre France
évidemment c'est l'ensemble des journaux
du centre de la France un mot d'abord
avec vous Julien sur cette affaire de
harcèlement moral qui touche l'acteur
Alain Delon
on est parti à Kushi notre journaliste
de La République du Centre Oriane Maxime
Klein est allé recueillir leur
étonnement ils ont deux mots les
habitants de Khushi dans le Loiret
surprise et satisfaction Alain Delon et
sa dame de compagnie était bien connue
dans le village une femme discrète nous
dit-il mais de manière tout aussi
discrète c'est un reportage à lire
effectivement dernière page des
quotidiens du groupe Centre France ce
matin
on va parler d'un autre sujet puisque
vous parlez du Tour de France également
dans vos pages ce matin supplément parce
que le tour arrive bientôt chez vous oui
il y a beaucoup de jeunes dans nos pages
ce matin Oriane 40 ans de France a
décidé de parcourir Limousin et
l'Auvergne de long large ce week-end la
grande boucle sera demain à Limoges et
le populaire du centre propose ce matin
un véritable guide de l'événement avec
un cahier spécial de 20 pages les
journalistes vous présente les étapes
les enjeux dont le peloton il vous donne
aussi toutes les clés pour suivre
l'événement sur le bord des routes il y
a du vélo dans nos pages des souvenirs
des duels enctiles Poulidor ces bagarres
historiques dans la région et puis
durant tout le week-end ce sera autour
de la rédaction de la montagne de vous
faire vivre ce grand événement qui est
la Grande Boucle on vous a préparé
plusieurs dossiers spéciaux tous les
jours dans les Editions papiers et
indirect web durant trois jours avec en
point d'orgue évidemment le retour du
Tour de France au sommet du Puy-de-Dôme
après une ascension spectaculaire et
pourquoi pas Oriane espérer une victoire
française ce week-end et on espère
effectivement ça fait partie des étapes
très attendues ce retour du tour dans le
Puy-de-Dôme on va parler d'un autre
sujet puisque il y a beaucoup de sujets
à lire aujourd'hui dans vos journaux
l'édition du Cantal propose à partir
d'aujourd'hui une grande série sur la
guerre de l'eau
ce matin la rédaction Aurillac face à
l'urgence du changement climatique face
au sécheresse à répétition nos
journalistes dans le Cantal font le
Paris du temps long il publieront un
épisode par semaine durant tous l'été
sûrement après on commence aujourd'hui
avec les agriculteurs quantaliens qui
s'adaptent en permanence à l'évolution
du climat aucun prétend détenir la
recette miracle mais tous à l'échelle de
leur exploitation change leur pratique
et testent de nouvelles solutions c'est
une série que l'on veut participative
avec des appels au lecteurs à lire
toutes les semaines durant tout cet été
madame la sénatrice Cohen je voudrais
vous poser une question vous et lui
parlementaire vous avez passé des
centaines d'heures sur les retraites au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée quand allez-vous
passer des centaines d'heures sur le
climat et la ressource en eau par
exemple quand allez-vous en faire une
priorité politique et dépasser vos
clivages
si tu dis excellente question parce
qu'effectivement ça cette question de
l'eau elle est vitale c'était là aussi
c'était un bien commun il y a plus de
1,4 milliards de personnes qui dans le
monde sont privées de cette ressource
essentielle j'ai pu le constater quand
j'ai fait un déplacement avec Pierre
Laurent nous sommes allés au Kurdistan
au nord-est de la Syrie et c'est aussi
une arme de guerre puisque
Erdogan et bien fait en sorte que avec
les barrages il abaisse le niveau de
l'eau notamment au niveau de l'Euphrate
pour priver les cures de dos ça se fait
aussi en Palestine avec les Israéliens
ça fait ça se fait dans aussi dans
beaucoup de dans beaucoup de régions
donc c'est un problème qui est crucial
qui est vital et vous avez raison il
faut absolument s'en emparer il y a des
expériences il faut savoir par exemple
qu'en France là vous avez parlé de
l'agriculture il y a des efforts il y a
à faire qui sont considérable mais moi
qui suis dans le dans le Val-de-Marne et
bien on constate aussi que du fait d'une
d'un réseau de distribution qui est
extrêmement vieillissant et bien il y a
un litre d'eau qui est éperdu sur sur 5
dans les fuites et qu'il faudrait donc
mettre de 1 à 3 milliards d'euros pour
entretenir ce réseau et d'ailleurs
et bien il y a dans mon département 9
mers de gauche qui se sont associés pour
prôner une régie publique de l'eau et le
président de cette de cette régie et le
premier adjoint de ma ville Gentilly je
fais un peu de pub fatagoon donc voilà
il y a des expériences intéressantes moi
j'aurais envie qu'on puisse les partager
pour agir ensemble parce que c'est une
question vitale
merci beaucoup Julien merci d'avoir été
avec nous regarder une du populaire du
centre c'est le tour de France vous en
avez parlé vivement demain c'est à la
une du populaire du centre et Julien
puisque c'est le dernier vendredi de la
saison je voudrais vous remercier vous
et toutes les équipes du groupe Centre
France d'avoir été avec nous tous les
vendredis pour nous donner à l'actualité
du centre de la France et on espère vous
retrouver avec grand plaisir la saison
prochaine merci Julien Bonnefoy d'avoir
été avec nous cette belle lucarne pour
la PQR tous les jours dans votre
émission c'est avec grand plaisir merci
à vous Julien un dernier mot Laurence
Cohen puisque vous allez quitter le
Sénat à la fin du mois de septembre
après 12 ans de mandat pourquoi ce choix
écoutez je pense que j'ai fait deux
mandats que c'était absolument
passionnant mais qu'après je pense
d'abord qu'il faut permettre à d'autres
d'avoir cette belle cette belle
expérience et puis il y a aussi une
histoire d'âge moi je considère que il
faut faire autre chose j'ai beaucoup
d'engagement je suis une militante
communiste de terrain
je suis une militante féministe donc il
y a encore de beaux combats
la politique parce que la politique
c'est notre vie c'est notre quotidien et
je veux continuer à essayer de
participer à une société d'émancipation
humaine donc je vais continuer à me
battre sur ce terrain là qu'est-ce que
vous retenez de vos 12 ans de mandat
écoutez une une riche une riche
expérience d'abord parce que c'est une
école quand même exigeante que que le
Sénat c'est pas c'est pas évident quand
on arrive c'est quand même très
impressionnant même quand on est une
militante politique une responsa
politique comme je l'ai je l'ai été on
est impressionné on dialogue avec avec
des des collègues avec des personnalités
avec des ministres voilà donc et puis et
puis on mène des missions qui sont
passionnantes et on a une palette
d'intervention qui est extrêmement riche
et justement vous avez beaucoup
travaillé pendant ces 12 ans quel est
votre plus grande fierté
oh là là j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai
vraiment j'en ai vraiment beaucoup donc
il y a des batailles que j'ai menées au
niveau de la santé même si elles n'ont
pas abouti que je vais continuer à
amener avec le tour de France des
hôpitaux avec ma famille politique les
communistes et là où on a porté des
propositions moi j'adore quand on crée
et on élabore des propositions avec les
acteurs et les actrices par exemple du
monde de la santé donc ça c'est c'est ce
sont des combats extrêmement importants
par rapport à la psychiatrie quand vous
allez justement hier on a vu un film à
mon initiative Adamant qui est un très
beau film sur les patients qui ont des
troubles psychiques et qui sont
accompagnés donc voilà on a des
rencontres on crée des choses et au
niveau de la délégation au droit des
femmes aussi beaucoup de combats pour
faire progresser cette lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes par rapport
à la pornographie en faire du décor
voilà là je viens de finir un rapport
sur la santé les femmes au travail bon
autant de autant de moments passionnants
et où on a pu tirer des enseignements
des recommandations ce que je regrette
c'est que le travail du Sénat qui est
très sérieux dans les dans les missions
d'information dans les dans les dans les
commissions d'enquêtes ne soient pas
pris à la hauteur de la qualité par le
gouvernement et que le gouvernement ne
s'en a pas suffisamment ce sera votre
dernier message sur cette antenne merci
Laurence Cohen merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous merci pour ces douze
années merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin et on a compris vous
allez continuer le combat politique le
message était clair merci à vous d'avoir
été avec nous dans 20 minutes dans le
club des territoires on parlera des
conclusions de la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur le fond Marianne rapport
qui accable Marlène Schiappa et la
gestion de ce fond ce sera le débat du
club d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité Claude ma luret nous
rejoint